bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 7 février appelle à la modération
de toutes les forces politiques
autrichienne par le président la
république thomas classe til you get
there nous a accordé un entretien
enregistré cet après midi au cours
duquel il choisit ses mots l'état tente
de s'appliquer à suresnes loi des 35
heures imposées aux autres les
négociations en cours dans la fonction
publique affecteront plus de 5 millions
de personnes fonctionnaires
le député alain vivien continue sa
croisade contre toutes les sectes
totalitaire nous évoquerons l'église
universelle du royaume de dieu qui
viennent s'installer dans une ancienne
salle de cinéma porno à paris première
diffusion de courts métrages intitulés
les scénarios sur la drogue toutes les
drogues toutes les formes de toxicomanie
sont abordés nous avons choisi un court
métrage avec pierre richer de la bande
dessinée enfin avec la planète des tel
jeu elle fait partie de la constellation
d'orion après aldebaran c'est la
nouvelle création de l'est au
dessinateur brésilien mais nous
ouvrirons cette édition en évoquant ce
qui est rare maintenant le kosovo le 24
mars prochain cela fera un an que le
tantad mais une guerre de bombardements
la veille le 23 mars dans la vallée de
la drenica une toute jeune fille qui
tait son billet son village de bakka sa
famille pour la france afin d'y subir
une opération chirurgicale urgente cette
enfance sur son lit d'hôpital et de
convalescence qu'elle a appris les
malheurs de la guerre affectant sa
famille il y a quelques jours elle est
enfin de retour dans son pays
une équipe de france 2 avec maryse
burgot aguicheur l'accompagnait entre
larmes et souvenirs sa fille elle
pensait ne jamais la revoir
alors ce retour c'est comme un miracle
auquel elle ose à peine croire
hier c'est tellement incroyable je sais
maintenant que ma fille est sauvé vous
savez c'est grâce à ce médecin la vie à
cause des médicaments mais ça va venir
normalement la cortisone a bouleversé
ses traits n'est quelle importance quand
chacun ici se souvient qu il y a dix
mois encore valbuena agoniser d'une
leucémie
une équipe de médecins du monde lui fit
alors quitté le kosovo pour subir en
france une greffe de moelle une vie
sauve et 1 to par hasard pendant que la
guerre tu es elle aussi au hasard qui a
été le plus dur s'il approuve en france
pendant ma convalescence que mon père
avait été tué par les serbes
et aussi que son frère
c'est à dire mon fils avaient été faits
prisonniers en serbie
l'histoire récente du village de
valbonne à l'histoire de sa famille est
un résumé de ce que fut la guerre au
kosovo est aujourd'hui la maison
familiale est encore à reconstruire tout
autant que les âmes les heures et des
heures dans une litanie sans fin sa mère
lit raconte les incendies les menaces
les morts et pour cette jeune fille de
18 ans est presque plus dur de n'avoir
pas été de ce cauchemar
ce qui est terrible pour moi c'est que
sept nuls 1 lorsque je suis parti pour
la france tout le monde était cinq
sortants et maintenant maintenant dit la
mère on n'a pas d'autre choix que de
s'en sortir dans quelques jours sa fille
devra rentrer en france pour terminer
son traitement phare et des rires
définitivement de sa maladie et brest au
kosovo la tension est très forte
actuellement entre serbes et albanais
2000 manifestants et
le nom de bernard kouchner ce matin des
violences dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi dernier ont fait au moins huit
morts et une explosion ont été entendus
ce matin mitrovic dans cette ville
déchirée entre deux communautés
bernard kouchner représentant spécial de
l'onu doit faire preuve de patience et
de sang froid il déclarait ce matin les
extrémistes des deux côtés ne gagneront
pas contre les extrémistes du parti
libéral de jörg haider en autriche le
président la république autrichienne
thomass costil a lancé un appel pour
contribuer à calmer la situation un
appel à la modération pour ne pas at il
dit endommagé la davantage la réputation
de l'autriche au plan international ce
qu'ils ont décidé de partager le pouvoir
à vienne avec les libéraux d'extrême
droite daider ce sont les conservateurs
du chancelier wolfgang schüssel and
consignes et patrick desmulie ont
enquêté parmi les conservateurs dont
certains ne font pas mystère de leur
malaise ou de leur réprobation après la
formation du gouvernement de coalition
le siège viennois du parti conservateur
en porte les traces tout le monde
n'apprécie pas qu'il est accepté de
former une coalition avec yang riders le
parti a gagné un chancelier le premier
depuis 1970 mais certains se demandent
s'il n'y a pas perdu un peu de son âme
un seul dirigeant du parti s'est élevé
contre ce choix
bernard d'orgue et maire adjoint de
vienne et voici comment il situe le
niveau de la menace
haider non ce n'est pas que je craigne
claire et instaure un régime nazi
ça c'est stupide mais je trouve que
c'est un politicien ou excessivement ces
opportunistes et vraiment rose produits
liste a propulsé ce n'est pas de gaieté
de coeur que les conservateurs ont
accepté la coalition aujourd'hui il
répète à l'envi qu'ils n'avaient le
choix qu'entre deux mauvaises solutions
ou faire des haltes et d'élections
anticipées avec une victoire de monsieur
ed
8 ou à prendre sur elle dans notre
coalition où nous avons la direction où
nous sommes
le chansonnier et le socialiser pour
pour ainsi dire c'est à dire le faire un
partenaire qui efface os comptabilité
qu'il a connues vernement qui devient un
mois populiste - démagogues qu'il ne
l'était dans le passé ça c'était les
choix que nous avons dieu car les
conservateurs insistent sur le fait que
jorg haider a progressé dans les
sondages depuis le début de la crise
selon eux les critiques européennes ne
desservent pas au contraire
depuis la fin de la semaine dernière
outre la position européenne décidant
d'isoler l'autriche politiquement on a
également noté la réprobation et les
menaces de rétorsion des états unis ou
encore le rappel de l'ambassadeur
d'israël et jorg haider fait peur compte
tenu de déclarations parfois pro-nazi
souvent révisionniste même si le puits
plusieurs semaines ils multiplient les
excuses et les réponses sur thème tout
ça c'est le passé nous avons enregistré
cet après-midi un entretien avec jorg
haider en duplex de vienne voici ce que
nous avons retenu de ces réponses à
commencer par celles sur la peur qu'il
suscite en europe
je ne comprends pas que l'union
européenne ait peur d'un petit parti
autrichien
en fait cela me semble un peu exagéré
mais vous verrez au fil des semaines et
des mois à venir que le parti libéral
mérite son nom et qu'il agit sur la base
des valeurs communes de l'europe et qui
conduira une bonne politique
monsieur dire comment expliquez vous le
succès votre parti car après tout
l'autriche se porte bien l'inflation est
à la baisse le chômage de 25% c'est un
record en europe et y ait une forte
croissance alors comment expliquez vous
que certaines thèses que vous défendez
et remporté un certain succès électoral
si simple à expliquer les autrichiens
souhaitait le changement parce que
trente ans de social
avec tous les abus de pouvoir que cela
représentait les copinages tout cela
était trop pour le citoyen donc ils se
sont clairement exprimés en faveur d'un
mouvement réformateur mouvement qui est
déjà associé de nombreux gouvernements
dans le pays qui avait déjà fait ses
preuves
monsieur rider vous avez critiqué
jacques chirac mais jacques chirac a
pris la tête d'une volonté européenne de
bloquer tout processus d'extrême droite
en autriche
est-ce que vous continuez à penser que
c'est pour des raisons de politique
intérieure française
ou est ce que vous prenez en
considération le fait que le président
chirac s'inquiète de différentes vos
propos de vos principes politiques
personnelles les jeux prend au sérieux
les préoccupations de chefs d'état
étrangers
lorsque leurs préoccupations sont le
résultat dans une réflexion longuement
mûri et d'une information très complète
je n'ai pas le sentiment que tous les
responsables européens qui critiquent à
l'heure habituelle l'autriche dispose
des informations nécessaires s'ils
détenaient ces informations il ne ferait
pas ce genre de déclarations je voudrais
vous vous proposer plusieurs mots et
puis vous demander votre définition à
chaque fois de chacun de ses mots quelle
est votre définition tout d'abord du mot
démocratie la souveraineté du peuple que
l'on ne devrait pas vouloir essayé
d'écarter de l'extérieur nazisme le net
un mouvement totalitaire du xxème siècle
dont il faut espérer que nous ne
rencontrerons plus jamais au 21e europe
europe à l'europe
c'est notre espace commun évoquera qui
doit reposer
de façon libérale sur les patries
européenne et qui ne doit pas être sous
la coupe du dirigisme bruxellois liberté
la liberté c'est la valeur suprême de
l'humanité il faut la défendre à ce
titre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
les autrichiens se défendront des
pressions extérieures contre leurs
libertés démocratiques
et puis enfin antisémitisme
l'antisémitisme
ceci est le visage très laid d'une
société intolérante qui heureusement
n'existe pas en autriche parce que
traditionnellement nous avons toujours
suivre vivre en paix avec les minorités
religieuses et ethniques soutien aux
minorités tel qu'il est pratiqué en
autriche pourrait être un exemple pour
la france qui a encore en la matière
quelques retards à rattraper
alors voilà les propos choisis de jörg
haider pour pour enregistrer donc cet
après midi en duplex depuis vienne
france a choisi ce qui nous a frappés
en écoutant ses propos du rider c'est un
ton coulé avec une volonté de séduire
manifeste your right there est
incontestablement un homme de charisme
que l'on peut trouver brillant
intelligent et qui aujourd'hui pèse ses
mots il se doit de si tu vires la
communauté internationale lui qui est
montré du doigt meilleurs riders doit se
méfier de ses propres démons jamais très
éloigné dans l'entretien qu'il nous a
accordé
quand il parle du respect des minorités
il n'hésite pas d'une certaine façon à
réécrire l'histoire de l'autriche
il faut se rappeler qu'en 1938 deux cent
mille juifs vivaient à vienne cent
cinquante mille seront expulsés et
dépossédés de leurs biens
cinquante mille autres exterminés dans
les camps et petite anecdote l'homme qui
l'avait choisi comme ministre de la
défense est réfutée par le président
autrichien thomas ce qu est-il
et bien cet homme là a fait campagne à
vienne l'automne dernier avec une
affiche et un slogan sur fond jaune à
traduisible mais qui veut dire plus ou
moins halte aux étrangers c'était un
slogan de goebbels ministre de la
propagande d'hitler
alors quelle que ce sous quel que soit
le discours policé de jorg haider
il n'y a pas de confusion il se place
bien à l'extrême droite sur l'échiquier
politique faisant entre autres de la
xénophobie son fonds de commerce
certes il faudra juger sa politique sur
des actes concrets et en carinthie dont
il est gouverneur n'oublions pas qu'il a
déjà fait fermer des écoles bilingues
merci françoise ambiguïté de l'europe
car d'une part la présidence d'autre
part la présidence portugaise de l'union
européenne a invité la ministre des
affaires sociales de république
d'autriche elisabeth s'y colle à
participer à une réunion ministérielle
informelle vendredi à lisbonne 10 bat
s'y colle m membre du parti d'extrême
droite de jörg haider
on retrouve l'idée de la modération dans
les propos à vienne jusque dans le
collège islamique qui vient d'ouvrir
manifestement les enseignants ne veulent
pas croire que la présence du parti
d'extrême droite au pouvoir
changera quelque chose à leur activité
reportage olivier werner et walter
richelle taxi turc à bienne il a trouvé
une école islamique pour sa fille
la première du genre en autriche une
école privée au centre de la ville avec
29 élèves mais qui s'apprête déjà à en
accueillir 300 9 filles 20 garçons de 10
à 12 ans réunis dans une même classe
sous le portrait du président autrichien
moi j'ai confiance
j'espère que ce qui se passe au niveau
politique ne touchera pas l'école un
autrichien sur trois a voté pour le
parti de jörg haider aux dernières
élections
le ministre de l'éducation même s'il est
issu des rangs des conservateurs peut
très bien maintenant ordonné la
fermeture de cet établissement
nous ne sommes pas pour la simulation
mais plutôt pour l'intégration
on veut garder nos traditions et nos
cultures sans déranger la vie des
autrichiens le directeur est autrichien
non musulmans il donne des cours
d'allemand
je peux le garantir si les élèves vont
jusqu'au bout de leur scolarité
nous aurons le niveau bac et pourront
même aller à l'université des cavernes
l'ouverture de cette école n'est pas
passé inaperçu dans le quartier juste à
côté le garagiste il préfère ne pas en
parler
mes voisins de palier il semble gêner
d'autres joue l'indifférence
chacun sa religion sa croyance moi ça
m'est égal
non ce n'est pas bon dans leur propre et
les étrangers dans une amicale mais
l'intégration est bien l'objectif de ces
enfants qui tous quand on les interroge
disent vouloir faire leur vie en
autriche tour avec les autrichiens
ils ne sont pas tous méchants avec lui à
l'heure du déjeuner le collège islamic
de vienne prend toutes les libertés
nécessaires pour assurer une éducation
religieuse très poussées à ses enfants
la classe se transforme en petite
mosquée le temps de la prière très
disciplinés à cet instant ils le sont
moins à l'heure de la récréation
alors que leur réserve l'avenir avec
l'arrivée des conservateurs et de
l'extrême droite au pouvoir
le collège est en sursis c'est le
nouveau gouvernement qui a toutes les
cartes en main c'est une femme
social-démocrate darja halonen qui a
remporté l'élection présidentielle en
finlande c'est la première femme
finlandaise à devenir chef de l'état
elle était jusqu'à leurs ministres des
affaires étrangères de finlande à
l'ouest de l'irlande du nord un attentat
à la bombe a été commis c'était hier
soir dans un hôtel de la localité à
majorité protestante dire vire stone
c'est un groupe intitulé ira de la
continuité qui a revendiqué cet attentat
le processus de paix déjà en cas si
suspension en irlande est donc très
menacé après cet attentat pour les 35
heures la suite en suite du détournement
de l'avion afghan avant d'évoquer les 35
heures en france clôt boeing avaient
quitté kaboul pour la ville afghane de
mazar i sharif à l'est du pays il y
avait cent soixante cinq personnes à
bord l'avion a finalement été détourné
jusqu'à l'aéroport de stansted près de
londres les discussions avec les
autorités policières anglais seront
longues
mais déjà quelques otages ont quitté
l'appareil londres correspondance de
benoît duquesne
ce sont les premiers échanges concrets
autour du boeing afghan isolés sur un
parking de l'aéroport de stanstead des
médicaments des boissons de la
nourriture d'une contrepartie sans doute
à la libération plutôt de 8 des 165
personnes qui souhaitent à bord de
l'appareil lors de son arrivée c'est la
technique britannique négocier jusqu'au
bout pour obtenir une reddition en
douceur mais ça n'empêche pas de se
préparer au pire
les forces spéciales des sas qui
s'entraînent toute l'année sur cet
aéroport commence à se mettre en place
jusqu'à présent les anglais sont
toujours parvenus dans ce genre de cas a
évité de donner l'assaut mais on ne sait
jamais car depuis son arrivé la nuit
dernière sur le sol britannique on sait
peu de choses sur les revendications des
pirates de l'air le détournement a
commencé la veille alors que le boeing
effectué une liaison intérieure afghane
il s'est d'abord posé en ouzbékistan
puis au kazakhstan et enfin à moscou à
chaque fois des passagers ont été
relâchés 23 ans tous avant d'atterrir en
angleterre les talibans au pouvoir à
kaboul accusent leur principal opposant
le commandant massoud d'être derrière
cette prise d'otages et refuse toute
négociation
nous n'avions pas l'intention de faire
d'accord ou d'entrer en négociation avec
les terroristes condamnons ces
terroristes et laissons le gouvernement
britannique l'a négocié et les
négociations se poursuivent d'après la
police elle pourrait durer très
longtemps
les pirates seraient au nombre de sept
ou huit armées de pistolets de grenades
d'armes blanches
mais la situation à bord seraient aussi
calme qu'il est possible pour une prise
d'otage qui dure maintenant depuis 37
heures en france pour les 35 heures
c'est au tour de la fonction publique
plus de 5 millions de personnes sont
concernées que ce soit d'un fonction
publique de l'état dans la fonction
publique territoriale ou encore en
secteur hospitalier les discussions
entre le ministre fonction publique
emile zuccarelli et sept fédérations de
fonctionnaires seront sans doute
compliqué car il faut prendre en compte
ce que l'on appelle les spécificités des
différentes composantes de la fonction
publique sur ces premières heures de
négociations voici le compte-rendu de
juliette boys à la location l'arrivée
est très attendu aussi le sourire et de
circonstance le ministre de la fonction
publique veut se montrer confiant pour
la première fois ils entament des
négociations sur les 35 heures avec des
représentants de toute la fonction
publique
recevez dans les accords cadres
je pense y parvenions bon espoir et
pourtant la tâche est compliquée par le
mini se retrouvent autour de la table
des négociations avec sept fédérations
de fonctionnaires tout déterminé il faut
aborder la question de l'emploi
beaucoup réclament un engagement écrit
sur des créations de postes tous veulent
s'assurer que le nombre de salariés ne
diminuera pas or jusqu'ici le
gouvernement s'est bien gardé d'aborder
la question
aussi après trois heures d'un premier
débat où aucune avancée n'a été
constatée
les syndicats ont tous la même
revendication le gouvernement doit
fournir un nouveau document avec des
propositions concrètes concernant
l'emploi comprend pas très bien
d'ailleurs quelles raisons gouvernement
qui a demandé aux entreprises privées de
réduire la durée du travail avec
création d'emplois reste aussi fermement
hostile à toute création d'emplois mais
c'est 35 heures nous en particulier on
est prêt à négocier quand il veut y
compris ce soir y compris demain c'est
rare qu'on n'acceptera pas qu'il lui
fasse porter le chapeau d'une
négociation sur la réduction du temps de
travail
il faut donc s'attendre à un marathon
car le ministre préféré terminer la
soirée avec un accord signé plutôt que
de renvoyer la négociation à chaque
ministère le suspense devrait durer une
bonne partie de la nuit à l'occasion de
ces négociations dans la fonction
publique qui nous a paru utile
d'effectuer un état des lieux succinct
du monde des fonctionnaires avec
justement certaines fameuse spécificités
comme antérion fronty avec jacques
gérard qu'elle soit infirmières qu'ils
soient policiers ou encore agent des
impôts
tous travaillent pour la fonction
publique des fonctionnaires comme on en
compte aujourd'hui en france 5 million
deux cent mille des fonctionnaires qu'il
faut payer une charge importante 640 2
milliards de francs en 1998 plus de 39 %
du budget de l'état mais d'un ministère
à l'autre d'un service à l'autre tous
n'effectue pas le même humour de 30 à 39
heures au ministère de la justice contre
29 à 39 heures à la culture ou encore
trente et une à 38 heures dans les
mairies les disparités sont donc très
forte y compris à l'intérieur d'une même
administration
c'est le constat de jacques rocher
auteur d'un rapport publié l'année
dernière un rapport qui a suscité la
polémique
même si ça n'était pas le but recherché
si je fais la même enquête dans le
secteur
et je suis sûr que je vais arriver aux
mêmes conclusions parce que il y a
partout ici dans telle région la fête la
ducasse la fête des sent-on la fête du
vin à bordeaux et setra tout ça et là
dedans il ya des jours de congés
supplémentaires qui diminue qui diminue
le teint effective de travail
le côté me réformer en profondeur la
fonction publique faire le tri
débroussailler les spécificités de
chaque profession aucun ministre ni est
encore arrivé claude goasguen pas plus
qu'un autre
et d'après lui la mise en place des 35
heures ne va rien arranger
je trouve que au delà du principe
général que pose la loi c'est ministère
par ministère qu'il faudrait discuter et
ne pas commencer par faire un accord
global pour aller vers les ministères
mais l'averse réformer le dossier est
donc sensible les mouvements de grèves à
répétition en témoigne seuls véritables
marges de manoeuvre pour le gouvernement
profitez des départs en retraite pour
imposer le même rythme de travail à tout
le monde et la marge de manoeuvre est
grande
selon les syndicats 48% des
fonctionnaires devraient partir en
retraite d'ici 2012
la réflexion sur le statut privilégié
des fonctionnaires conduit parfois à des
changements radicaux ce n'est qu'un
exemple ce qui va suivre mais c'est en
suisse et dans le canton de vaud
désormais les élus dans ce canton décidé
d'employer de rémunérer leurs policiers
selon leur mérite
reportage d'intérim oiseaux et
jean-francois monier l'uniforme n'a pas
changé il fait toujours son effet
pourtant malgré les apparences
une petite révolution s'est accompli ce
policier n'est plus fonctionnaires mais
simple employé du jour au lendemain il
peut être licencié pour des raisons
économiques
fini l'avancement automatique désormais
le salaire est au mérite un recul tenue
en échange davantage octroyant
particulier aux plus âgés on a donné des
congés supplémentaires à partir d'un
certain âge ce qui est bien pour les
gens qui arrivent à 50 ans le salaire au
mérite
je trouve que c'est une bonne chose
avant ça crée un petit peu sur les
années de service plus sur la qualité du
travail du policier
trop risqué pour certains novatrice en
tout cas avec sa réforme madame le maire
fait figure de modèle dans tout le
canton
son credo pour mieux gérer il faut
responsabiliser les personnels
l'objectif premier n'est pas de faire
des économies
les gens doivent prendre conscience que
il ya derrière eux un conseil
d'administration qui lui qui paie des
impôts finalement et qu' ils doivent
rendre des comptes à ces gens là et
qu'ils doivent être performants
c'est peut-être un nouveau moyen
d'accueil aussi c'est une volonté de de
prendre le citoyen comme un citoyen
clients et plus comme un citoyen
simplement aux payeurs une expérience
pilote que tous ne souhaite pas voir
étendue ainsi à neuchâtel et même si la
grève n'est pas une tradition locale
les syndicats tentent de mobiliser ici
après les enseignants les personnels de
santé nous allons nous organiser pour
que ça ne se passe pas position opposée
parce que le salaire au mérite va contre
la solidarité entre les gens sur le lieu
de travail ça sème la division sacem la
compétition et c'est inutile nous avons
besoin de pouvoir collaborer ensemble
pour pouvoir travailler comme il faut au
service de la population et de fait avec
la loi adoptée par l'assemblée le 6
octobre c'est toute la fonction publique
poste chemin de fer impôts qui effrayé
de s'aligner sur le secteur privé et est
en compétition sur le marché du travail
avec des entreprises privées
on recrute des mêmes sources de
personnel et ça veut dire aussi qu'on
doit on goûte on devrait appliquer les
mêmes principes soient dans la fixation
des salaires une tendance libérale qui a
conquis depuis longtemps la suisse
alémanique et que les suisses romands
francophone est minoritaire n'arriveront
pas inversée deux ans après la mort du
préfet erignac qu'un nouveau groupe
clandestin tient une conférence de
presse dans le maquis de corse-du-sud
des hommes encagoulés vous les voyez se
disant appartenir armata corsa se
prononce plutôt en faveur du dialogue
politique actuellement antheaume et par
le premier ministre
depuis plus d'un an la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
sectes présidée par alain vivien
multiplient les investigations contre
toutes les religions sectaire
totalitaire qui portent atteinte je cite
à l'ordre public et à la dignité de la
personne humaine dans le rapport qui
vient d'être remis au premier ministre
on trouve la nécessité d'une coopération
internationale
mais celle-ci est difficile avec les
états unis où la législation est
infiniment plus tolérante à l'égard des
sectes au nom de la liberté de culte le
rapport vie d'alain vivien souligne
également la recrudescence de l'activité
des sectes dans les départements et les
territoires d'outre-mer et puis la
nécessité d'intéresser les entreprises à
la lutte antisecte alain vivien on a
fait une véritable croisade ce qui lui a
valu beaucoup d'inimitiés une équipe de
france 2 avec joël bruandet grégoire au
zinal l'a suivi dans son travail
la popularité d'alain vivien pour la
mesure d'abord auprès des sectes elle
même nous sommes devant le palais de
justice de marseille en septembre
dernier
pendant que plusieurs de leurs membres
sont jugés pour escroquerie
ces scientologues manifestent pour la
liberté et contre alain vivien
le monde veut l'intéressé lui est
habitué depuis longtemps à
l'intimidation et aux menaces sélectif
seule concession ce garde du corps qui
le suit dans tous ses déplacements
depuis plus de 15 ans alain vivien est
considéré comme un des grands
spécialistes du phénomène sectaire des
sectes qui refusent le plus souvent la
transparence sur leurs revenus
alors elle se cache derrière le statut
d'une simple association loi 1901 les
sectes très habilement ne veulent pas
entrer dans les normes congrégation nice
mutuel parce qu'elle serait oublier la
tremblante elle se situe donc au niveau
de l'association de droit commun du bsl
par exemple l'association de pêcheurs à
la ligne de tel ou tel village ou d'une
association sportive ce qui est tout à
fait incompatible avec les objectifs
réels qu'elle poursuit depuis octobre 98
alain vivien est à la tête de la très
officielle mission interministérielle de
lutte contre les sectes une mission
surtout fait d'informations auprès de
tous ceux qui sont concernés de
l'éducation nationale aux pouvoirs
publics en passant par les futurs chefs
d'entreprise comme ce jour-là à hec
alain vivien a pris à débusquer les
sectes sont les sectes aujourd'hui je
dirais qu'elles sont dans la formation
professionnelle et dans les thérapies et
que ce sont les deux gisements qu'elle
exploite sous le masque religieux dans
le rapport remis cette après midi au
premier ministre alain vivien souligne
justement les risques d'emprise
sectaires sur les entreprises la mission
interministérielle estime par ailleurs
qu'une reprise en main est nécessaire
dans les départements d'outre-mer où
selon certaines estimations 20 à 25% de
la population ils seraient membres d'une
secte religieuse c'est l'église
scientologie qui est en tête de tous les
rapports sur les religions sectaire mais
il ya parfois d'autres naissances ou
renaissance curieuse dans ce secteur
ainsi l'église universelle du royaume de
dieu elle revendique six millions de
fidèles dans le monde dont la moitié au
brésil elle vient de racheter une salle
de spectacle dans le 10e arrondissement
à paris une seule qui était devenue
celle d'un cinéma pour nous
reportage patrick fandio et alain du bas
derrière le rideau de fer un chantier
discret qu'est ce qu'on est en train de
construire heures
tu ne parleras pas aux journalistes
c'est un commandement du chef de
chantier
c'est quoi la nature des travaux la
présence de la caméra va momentanément
stoppé les travaux de démolition
mais dans quelques mois la scala cette
ancienne salle de spectacle célèbre dans
les années 30
cet ancien cinéma pornographique va être
transformée en salle de prière de
l'église universelle du royaume de dieu
tout irait pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des cieux si cette église
n'était pas classé comme mouvements
sectaires dans un précédent rapport
parlementaire dans leur salle de prière
comme celle ci toujours dans le 10ème
arrondissement
on chasse le démon lors de bruyantes
cérémonie quelques milliers en france 6
millions dans le monde
l'église universelle du royaume de dieu
est un mouvement prospère tout puissant
brésil où il a été fondé il y dispose de
ses propres députés surtout de sa chaîne
de télévision
face à un tel mouvement les élus
municipaux tentent de trouver la parade
pour stopper cette expansion
la mairie du 10e s'opposera à tout
permis de construire qui fera abandonner
ses salles de spectacle et que
maintenant apprenant que c'est une secte
à la réputation ses douteuses
qui vont s'installer là
nous nous y opposerons encore plus
volontiers l'église a promis de
s'expliquer dans quelques jours sur son
projet mais déjà elle fait remarquer
qu'un lieu de culte qui remplace un
cinéma pornographique
c'est toujours mieux premier jour d'un
procès devant la cour d'assises de paris
procès d'un homme accusé d'avoir tué ou
grièvement blessé six femmes c'était en
1996 ce français d'origine sénégalaise
s'est présenté au procès comme victime
d'un sortilège vaudou compte rendu
d'audience dominique verdeilhan pour ses
parents mamadou traoré était tantôt le
don de dieu tantôt l'enfant du diable
c'est en 6e que l'accusé tombe dans la
délinquance vols avec violence raquettes
puis plus tard trafic de drogue en 96
son chemin croise six femmes de 11 à 70
ans deux décéderont après avoir été
violée et frappée violemment à la tête
une fureur destructrice selon les
experts je compatis au mal que je leur
ai fait dit il aux victimes puis il
ajoute tout cela c'est la faute du
gri-gri que m'a offert mon père pour me
nuire
traoré mais tous ces malheurs sur le
compte du marabout même sa
séropositivité
c'est de la sorcellerie que j'ai dans le
sens finit-il par dire ce matin et
reconnaît sa responsabilité c'est après
midi finalement il échappe à sa
responsabilité en disant qu'il ait tenté
bon c'est vrai que ce matin
il a reconnu l'ensemble des faits et les
choix une chose et puis il a présenté
dit que ça fait trois ans et demi on les
attend au même âge ou traoré qui
cherchent à passer pour une victime de
la sorcellerie succès d'un autre visage
alors que ce soir son père est à la
barre des témoins l'accusé lui crache
tout son venin tout son mépris avec une
haine une force et une intensité qui
finit plus tôt par p des contrôles
un nouveau cas de méningite des skis ce
matin il s'agit d'un cas de méningite de
type b chez un adolescent de 15 ans
résidant à dagneux dans l'ain
ce lycéen est scolarisé au collège
gabriel rosset de lyon il aurait des
séances d'entraînement sportif au
collège salvador allende de bourgoin
jallieu dans l'isère
là où deux autres cas de méningite ont
été enregistrées la semaine dernière
des scénarios sur la drogue c'est une
nouvelle série de courts-métrages 24 au
total lancée à l'initiative du centre
régional d'information et de prévention
du sida
toutes les formes de toxicomanie sont
abordés voici un exemple avec
l'alcoolisme l'on retrouve l'acteur
pierre richard présentation agnès
gardait et claude bernier de litres de
rouge sa dose quotidienne sont pas et
chancelant alors que la journée vient de
commencer
tous les jours les mêmes scènes se
répètent c'est le drame ordinaire d'un
alcoolique
je ne sais pas quand mais morale c'est
une manière de
de suggérer quelles peuvent être les
difficultés d'existence en frappèrent
une fille appartement où le père bois et
tout ça les dix ans peu de choses et peu
de monde hagneré avec simplement des
regards c'est très bien dans le bus la
confrontation battant et imaginez bien
qu'on ne peut pas brader les
adolescentes se moque de cet homme aux
allures de clochard sans savoir qu'il
s'agit du père de l'une d'entre elles
photo jt dégoûté raison inconnue et
l'alcool ça ronge et pièges n'importe
quoi david de la palme ancien banquier
d'affaires a vécu cet enfer pendant 25
ans je faisais tous les efforts
possibles pour cacher c'était un
alcoolisme et mais qui au moment de
toucher le fond et et je ne peux cacher
parce qu'un jour où vos enfants vous ont
démasqué n'ont jamais dit en face ça
jamais jamais j'ai eu je sentais le
regard c'était dans le monde dit que je
le sentais le plus c'était la façon dont
il me regardait
l'alcool et la drogue qui pèse le plus
lourd en france 43 mille personnes
meurent chaque année de maladies liées à
l'alcoolisme monté jusqu'à de champ pour
y chercher ton sommeil noir
moi je reste on bat soir
ai je droit
oui je prends
et je crois
enfin j'espère
diffusion de ces scénarios sur la drogue
toutes les drogues diffusion de ces
courts métrages sur toutes les chaînes
de télévision et dans les salles de
cinéma du sport du football avec la
coupe d'afrique des nations sont déjà
qualifiés pour les demi finales le
cameroun qui a battu l'algérie et
l'afrique du sud qui a battu le ghana
depuis aujourd'hui surprise regardez
bien
l'egypte tenante du titre en verre a été
battue par la tunisie sur un pénalty 1 à
0 ce soir c'est le oui geria qui sera
opposé au sénégal et puis on a appris la
démission du français henri michel
entraîneur de l'équipe du maroc éliminé
de la phase finale de cette coupe
d'afrique des nations la sortie d'une
nouvelle bande dessinée dans les mondes
d'aldébaran aux éditions dargaud le
scénariste et dessinateur les eaux
d'origine brésilienne
voici cette bande dessinée propose
bételgeuse la planète c'est dans la
constellation d'orion où toutes les
histoires fantastiques sont possibles ah
ben mustapha et nathalie gallet et vox
léo hauteur de viande de bande dessinée
de science-fiction dans le monde de léo
l'agitation foisonnent l'atmosphère est
plutôt moite
elle est même parfois torrides normal
l'auteur est né à rio de janeiro dans le
monde de léo la soldatesque vous
brutalise pour un oui ou pour un non
normal cet ancien militant gauchiste a
connu la dictature militaire sud
américaine ingénieur de formation
les oc tourner progressivement vers la
bande dessinée par n'importe laquelle la
bd franco belge
on achetait au brésil
les années soixante dix pilotes mettent
alors à qui je ne veux pas être nous
tous les ça génial d' il gémit depuis
c'était pas évident il faut que je fasse
ça dans ma vie il faut que j'efface
c'est ça que je vais faire raconter des
histoires avec des albums de bolt est
comme ça et c'était sur l'avenir en
france à 37 ans léo débarque à paris
avec plumes ses bagages quelques
économies en poche et quelques scénarios
sous le bras ils frappent à la porte des
éditeurs en vain les audois ronger son
frein et travailler dans la pub
ce n'est que dix ans après son arrivée
en france qu'il publie sa propre bd
aldebaran aldebaran planète de la
constellation du taureau colonisés par
détériore un climat plus doux des
créatures plus menaçante mais rarement
dangereuse pour l'homme un monde
parallèle accueillant seulement troublée
par un phénomène mystérieux surgi d'un
immense océan la maîtrise avec son style
dépouillé les eaux a déjà embarqué plus
de 200 mille lecteurs la vie est décrite
une façon extrêmement plate dans cette
attitude fameux émerge une une
succession d'émotion qui s'installe et
futile qui prennent pas suffisamment
puissant pour vous emmener sur une autre
planète
après cinq épisodes sur aldebaran les
personnages viennent d'investir l'étoile
bételgeuse au plus grand plaisir des
fans de léo il dit sont encore pour
quatre autres au top voilà l'album dont
on vient de parler d'elle mostafa
bételgeuse la planète aux éditions
dargaud
nous arrivons à la fin de cette édition
je vous rappelle l'actualité concernant
les négociations actuellement en cours
au ministère de la fonction publique
autour du mythe grec
il y a sept fédérations syndicales et
cela représente des négociations sur les
35 heures qui concerne plus de 5
millions de personnes fonctionnaires de
la fonction publique
merci voilà pour l'actualité nous
passons maintenant à la météo avec
nathalie rihouet dans quelques secondes
puisse le spécial a dit à l'endroit
présenté par mireille dumas sur le thème
des enfants disparus fugue ou enlèvement
à 23h05 vous retrouverez mots croisés
mais qu'arlette chabot et alain diomède
dont le thème est l'hôpital et malade
invité claude evin bernard debré des
médecins des urgentistes et les
infirmières et puis à 0 heure quarante
votre dernier journal de la rédaction en
compagnie de laurence ostolaza demain à
7h50
françoise laborde recevra henri
hajdenberg le président du congrès juif
européen président du crif également
ensuite à 13h vous retrouvez carole
gaessler et rachid arhab ici même à
demain 20 heures dont soir merci
tous